we grew up believing that the hymen is a
proof of virginity but it turns out we
were wrong what we discovered is that
the poplars story we're told about
female virginity is based on two
anatomical myths the truth has been
known in medical communities for over a
hundred years yet somehow these two
myths continue to make life difficult
for women around the world the first
myth is about blood it tells us that the
hymen breaks and bleeds the first time a
woman has vaginal sex in other words if
there is no blood on the sheets
afterwards then the woman was simply not
a virgin the second myth is a logical
consequence of the first since the hymen
is thought to break and bleeds people
also believe that it actually disappears
always in some way radically altered
during a woman's first intercourse if
that were true one would easily be able
to determine if a woman is a virgin or
not by examining her genitals by doing a
virginity check so that's our two myths
virgins bleed and hymens are lost
forever now this may sound like a minor
issue to you why should you care about
an obscure little skin fall on the
female body but the truth is this is
about so much more than an anatomical
misunderstanding the myths about the
hymen have lived on for centuries
because they have cultural significance
they have been used as a powerful tool
in the effort to control women's
sexuality in about every culture
engine and historical decade women are
still mistrusted shamed harmed and in
the worst cases subjected to honor
killings if they don't bleed on their
wedding night
other women are forced through degrading
virginity checks simply to obtain a job
to save their reputation or to get
married like in Indonesia where women
are systematically examined to enter
military service after the Egyptian
uprisings in 2011 a group of female
protesters were forced to undergo
virginity checks by their military in
Oslo doctors are examining the hymens of
young girls to reassure parents that
their children are not ruined and sadly
the list goes on
women are so afraid not to live up to
the myths about the hymen that they
choose to use different virginity quick
fixes to assure a bleeding that could be
plastic surgery known as reversion ation
it could be vials of blood poured on the
sheets after sex or fake hymens bought
online complete with theater Bloods and
a promise to kiss your deep dark secrets
goodbye by telling girls that no deed
can be kept secrets that their bodies
will reveal them no matter what we have
endowed them with fear girls are afraid
of ruining themselves either through
sport play tampon use or sexual activity
we have curtailed their opportunities
and their freedoms it's time we put an
end to the virginity fraud it's time we
break the myths about the hymen ones and
for all we are medical students sexual
health workers and the authors of the
wonder Down Under that's a popular
science book about the female genitals
and in our experience people seem to
believe that the hymen is some kind of a
seal covering the vaginal opening in
Norwegian it is even called the Virgin
membrane and with this we picture
something fragile something easily
destructible something you can rip
through perhaps like a sheets of plastic
wrapping you may have wondered why we
brought a hula hoop onstage today we'll
show you now it is very hard to hide
that something has happened to this hoop
right it is different before and after I
punched it the seal is broken and unless
we change the plastic it won't get back
to its intact States so if we wanted to
do a virginity check on this hoop right
here right now that would be very easy
it's easy to say that this hoop is not a
virgin anymore but the hymen is nothing
like a piece of plastic you can wrap
around your food or a seal in fact it's
more like this a scrunchie or rubber
bands the hymen is a rim of tissue at
the outer opening of the vagina and
usually it has a doughnut or a Halfmoon
shape with a large central hole but this
varies Lots and sometimes hymens can
have fringes it can have several holes
or it can consist of lobes in other
words hymens naturally vary a lot in
lips
and that is what makes it so hard to do
a virginity check now that we know a bit
more about the hyneman's Anatomy it's
time to get back to our two myths
virgins bleeds hymens are lost forever
but the hymen doesn't have to break at
all the hymen is like a scrunchie in
function as well as in looks and you can
stretch as when she writes you can
stretch a hymen too in fact it's very
elastic and for a lot of women the hymen
will be elastic enough to handle a
vaginal intercourse without sustaining
any damage for other women the hymen may
tear a bit to make room for the penis
but that won't make it disappear but it
may look a bit different from before it
naturally follows the you can't examine
the hyneman's to check for virginity
status this was noted over a hundred
years ago in 1906 by the Norwegian dr.
Mary Jean sets she examined a
middle-aged sex worker I concluded that
her genitalia were reminiscent of a
teenage virgin but that makes sense
right because if her hymen was never
damaged during sex then what were we
expecting to see since hymens come in
every shape and form it is difficult to
know if a dent or a folder nest is there
because of previous damage or if it's
just a normal anatomical variant the
absurdity of virgin testing is
illustrated in a study done on 36
pregnant teenagers when doctors examined
their hymens they could only find clear
signs of penetration into out of the 36
so unless you believe in 34 cases of
virgin births we must all agree that
also our second myth has taken a vital
blow you simply cannot look a woman
between her legs and reads her sexual
story like most myths the myths about
the hymen are untrue
there is no virgin seal that magically
disappears after sex and half a virgins
can easily have sex without bleeding we
wish we could say that by removing these
myths everything would be okay
that shame harm and honor killings would
all just disappear but of course it's
not that simple sexual oppression of
women comes from something much deeper
than a simple anatomical
misunderstanding about the properties of
the hymen it's a question of cultural
and religious control of women's
sexuality and that is much harder to
change but we must try as medical
professionals this is our contribution
we want every girl parent and coming
husband to know what the hymen is and
how it works we want them to know that
the hymen can't be used as a proof of
virginity and that way we can remove one
of the most powerful tools used to
control young women today after telling
you this you may wonder what the
alternative is for if we cannot use the
hymen as a proof of virginity for women
then what should we use we opt for using
nothing
if you
[Music]
if you really want to know if a woman is
a virgin or not ask her but how she
answered that question is her choice
thank you
[Applause]